DC's cinematic history spans over half a
century - and in that time they've released
some of the most memorable comic book movies
ever made. From Batman's beginnings to Zack
Snyder's Justice League, these are the most
iconic scenes from every live action DC movie.
1966's Batman contains a scene that perfectly
encapsulates the campy tone of '60s-era Batman.
Upon discovering a smoking bomb in the United
Underworld's HQ, Batman dashes out of the
building to dispose of it. Unfortunately, he
runs into... well, basically everything - from a
mother with a baby to a gaggle of nuns to a full
brass band. Cue Batman's now-legendary lament:
"Some days you just can't get rid of a bomb."
Luckily, the ever-resourceful Caped Crusader
eventually manages to dispose of the bomb,
while ducking beside some lead pipes
to shield himself from the blast.
Utterly ridiculous and totally hilarious, this
scene is Adam West's Batman at its absolute best.
Considered to be a classic film in its own
right, 1978's Superman was one of the first
DC films to actually take its hero seriously -
and part of that means following a young Clark
Kent's life in Smallville. As such, by the end
of the movie's first act, most audiences will be
eager to see Superman make his proper debut.
Luckily, they won't be disappointed, either.
Although the Man of Steel first
appears in the Fortress of Solitude,
he truly reveals himself to the world after a
disastrous helicopter takeoff threatens the life
of Lois Lane. Seeing he's needed, Clark Kent
races across the street, rips open his shirt,
and reveals the famous "S" emblem on his
chest. After spinning through a revolving door,
Superman takes to the sky and catches Lois
mid-fall. Accompanied by John Williams'
classic Superman score, this iconic moment set
the standard for all future Superman movies.
Superman II sees Clark Kent sacrifice
his powers to be with Lois Lane.
Unfortunately, his decision coincides with the
reappearance of a trio of Kryptonian criminals,
led by the nefarious General Zod. Realizing
that only Superman can stop this threat,
Clark manages to re-energize his
powers at the Fortress of Solitude.
Back in Metropolis, Zod and his cronies
invade the Daily Planet and threaten to kill
everyone in the building - unless the "son of
Jor-El" appears. Just as all hope seems lost,
the wind blows, the music swells, and a
familiar caped figure soars into the room.
"General, would you care to step outside?"
Superman is famous for his dramatic
entrances and last-second arrivals,
and this moment is the best of the very best.
The first Swamp Thing movie was released
when comic book films were still trying
to strike a balance between serious
storytelling and campy comedy. As such,
the main character comes across as kind of
a B-movie monster, albeit a more heroic one.
It only seems natural, then, that the scene in
which Swamp Thing fights his archenemy, Arcane,
is legendarily cheesy. Both characters
are obviously wearing rubber suits,
and the bestial Arcane for some reason
decides to use a sword against his opponent.
This is comic book cinema at its absolute goofiest
— not that there's anything wrong with that.
Despite its reputation as one of the weaker
entries in the Superman movie franchise,
Superman III contains one of the most
iconic scenes in Superman movie history:
The eerie sequence in which Clark Kent
battles Superman. After Gus Gorman
creates a synthetic form of Kryptonite, he
exposes Superman to the toxic substance,
which eventually splits the hero into two
beings: A good Clark Kent and an evil Superman.
The two then come to blows in a junkyard, where
Superman tries to destroy his nerdy alter ego,
once and for all. Clark refuses to succumb,
however, and finally strangles his corrupt
counterpart, causing the evil Superman to
vanish into thin air. In the aftermath,
Clark rips open his shirt, showing off his bright
"S" shield, and soars away as Superman reborn.
It's a magnificent sequence in - let's
face it - a less-than-magnificent movie.
Though it ultimately failed to expand the
Superman movie franchise, Supergirl still
offers a memorable performance
by Helen Slater as Kara Zor-El.
And arguably her finest moment takes
place when she first arrives on Earth,
where she discovers both the wonders of
the natural world and her new superpowers.
Kara picks up a rock and accidentally crushes
it in her hand. She plucks a flower, makes it
bloom with her heat vision, and is shocked and
delighted when she finds herself floating. As
she grows more comfortable somersaulting through
the air, Supergirl takes her first proper flight,
soaring through the clouds and finally
settling down to watch the sunset.
This is a genuinely beautiful scene, unlike
any you'll find in the other Superman movies.
It's just a shame the rest of
the movie doesn't measure up.
Although it's generally regarded
as the worst Superman movie,
one sequence in Superman IV stands out: The battle
between Superman and his solar-powered clone,
Nuclear Man. Created by Lex Luthor to
destroy the Man of Steel, Nuclear Man
decides to first "have fun" by flying around
the world and causing a number of disasters.
Naturally, Superman follows
Nuclear Man and manages to set
everything right - although budget constraints
and some weak storytelling leads him to develop
some strange new powers in the process.
Still, despite the poor special effects,
it's actually a lot of fun seeing Nuclear
Man wreak havoc on famous world landmarks.
By 1989, Swamp Thing had undergone a revival in
DC comics, thanks to superstar writer Alan Moore's
reconfiguration of the character. The Return
of Swamp Thing largely ignored these changes,
however, opting instead to lean into
the comic B-movie side of things.
Dick Durock reprises his role as Swamp Thing,
but displays a more casual attitude as he
takes the fight to several new monsters.
One particularly funny scene unfolds when
a baseball bat-wielding Swamp Thing saves a
couple kids from some bad guys. When the kids
try to take a photo of him for the tabloids,
Swamp Thing not only obliges, he has one
of the kids pose with him in the shot.
If only Bigfoot was this accommodating.
Tim Burton's 1989 film Batman set a new tone
for live-action depictions of the Dark Knight.
No longer the campy crimefighter of the 1960s
TV show, Batman could now be portrayed as
the brooding, serious hero he was in the comic
books. And nowhere is this made more clear than
with his first appearance, in which he steps
out of the shadows to take down two muggers.
"What are you?"
"I'm Batman."
With these two simple words, Keaton set a whole
new precedent for the character of Batman.
Unsurprisingly, this iconic line has been
repeated in practically every Batman film and
TV series since, as it so effectively communicates
everything you need to know about the Dark Knight.
"I am Batman!"
"I'm Batman."
"Hey, I'm Batman."
And we all knowexactly what that means - because Keaton made
it perfectly clear the first time around.
One thing that's certain about Tim Burton's
Batman movies is that the villains almost always
overshadow the hero. Take Catwoman, for example.
Michelle Pfeiffer's Selina Kyle goes through a
dramatic character arc in the film, starting
out as a humble secretary to her corrupt boss
Max Shreck. After he pushes her out
of a window, Selina is revived by
a colony of cats, and transforms into
a more aggressive version of herself.
Her first big action scene establishes
exactly who this Catwoman is. When she sees
a mugger assault a young woman, Catwoman
brutally kicks the thug into submission,
clawing his face into a bloody pulp
for good measure. And then she does
something even more surprising: she
assaults the would-be victim, too.
"You make it so easy, don't you? Always
waiting for some Batman to save you."
That's Selina Kyle, alright.
Say what you will about the Joel Schumacher Batman
films, but they at least have a distinctive style
all their own. Batman Forever sets that
tone right away in its opening scene,
in which Bruce Wayne dons his
Batsuit and chooses his weapons.
This scene is so instantly memorable that
it's even parodied within the same movie,
when Bruce dons a new prototype suit
and gives the audience a close-up of
his now-infamous "Bat butt." The sequence is
also repeated in the sequel, Batman & Robin,
and is now considered one of the Dark Knight's
most infamous and embarrassing moments.
Batman & Robin is a movie that seems
dead-set on one-upping itself with
increasingly bizarre and ridiculous
moments. One scene, however, elevates
the silliness to almost unbelievable levels.
While appearing at a charity benefit auction,
Batman and Robin are exposed to pheromone-laden
love dust, courtesy of Poison Ivy. They then
proceed to bid against each other for the right
to date the villainess. And then… this happens.
"Seven million…
never leave the cave without it."
Although the Bat-credit card is one of the most
heavily-ridiculed gadgets in the Caped Crusader's
long history, it is at least a fun call-back to
the endearing absurdity of the '60s version of
Batman. And, if nothing else, it also emphasizes
Bruce Wayne's one true superpower: his money.
In the comics, Steel is John Henry Irons, a
weapons designer who builds an armored suit
to honor Superman after the Man of Steel dies
fighting Doomsday. The movie version, however,
simply has John Henry and his partner Susan Sparks
build the suit to take down a weapons dealer.
In the film's climax, Burke's thugs
capture Sparks. But, as she quickly shows,
she's installed a few surprises in her chair.
While the film was rightly panned on its release,
this scene is, at least, surprisingly
memorable for its sheer ridiculousness alone.
The 2004 Catwoman movie has been widely
criticized for its nonsensical plot, bad acting,
and poor special effects. Given that the film
was nominated for seven Golden Raspberry Awards,
it won't surprise you to learn that the movie's
most iconic scene isn't exactly a great one.
The scene in question is the infamous basketball
scrimmage between Patience and her love interest,
Detective Tom Lone. After being challenged
to a one-on-one basketball game by some kids,
Patience uses her cat-like coordination
and agility to flirt with Lone,
eventually dunking the ball from the
free-throw line. It's a silly, unnecessary,
and horribly edited scene that is thoroughly
ridiculed to this day… much like the movie itself.
Keanu Reeves may have seemed like a
strange choice to play DC's chain-smoking,
magic-wielding anti-hero Constantine at the time,
but the film has since gone on to
gain something of a cult following.
One of the movie's best scenes comes when
Constantine attempts to find a detective's
twin sister by going to Hell and looking for
her there. In the process, he braves an army
of demons to snatch her hospital wristband,
hoping to at least return it to her sister.
That image of Constantine reaching upward
for the wristband as devils attempt to drag
him down to Hell perfectly symbolizes the
character's struggles with his own demons.
It's not exactly subtle, but this is a
great sequence in a surprisingly good movie.
Batman Begins was arguably the first Batman
film that was truly about Batman. Offering
an in-depth look at the childhood trauma that
shapes Bruce Wayne, the movie spends much of
its runtime showing Bruce training and growing
before he finally reveals himself as Batman.
And it's one of these moments that stands out as
its most iconic scene. At the start of the film,
a young Bruce Wayne develops a phobia of bats
after falling into a cave near Wayne Manor.
Later, having lost his parents and mastered
his fears under the guidance of Ra's al Ghul,
Bruce returns to the cave, and is once
again attacked by bats. This time, however,
Bruce remains calm and lets the bats circle
him, immersing himself in his worst fear.
He might not be wearing the suit yet, but in
that moment, Bruce Wayne truly becomes Batman.
Bryan Singer's Superman Returns was intended
to be a continuation of Christopher Reeve's
Superman films, but was criticized for
its somber depiction of the Man of Steel
and the unnecessary introduction
of Superman's son, Jason.
Nevertheless, Superman Returns is filled
with plenty of visually stunning sequences
in which Superman shows off his god-like
abilities. One particularly memorable scene
occurs shortly after Superman's return, when he
floats above the Earth and uses his super-hearing
to listen to all the voices on the planet.
As soon as he hears a single cry for help,
he leaps into action and plummets back down
to Earth. Whatever his flaws may be, Superman
is supposed to be Earth's greatest protector
- and this scene demonstrates that in full.
Heath Ledger's magnetic performance as the Joker
in The Dark Knight earned him a well-deserved
posthumous Oscar. And while virtually all of
Ledger's scenes could be considered iconic in
their own right, the interrogation scene between
Batman and the Joker is probably the best of all.
In this scene, the Joker takes
the opportunity offered by his
face-to-face with Batman to deliver some of
the best lines in comic book movie history.
"See, I'm not a monster. I'm
just ahead of the curve."
This is a truly gripping scene, made even more
disturbing by the fact that the Joker makes
no effort to defend himself when things get
violent - yet still manages to get everything
he wants. As far as depictions of the Joker go,
it really doesn't get much better than this.
While there are a few slight differences between
Zack Snyder's Watchmen adaptation
and the comic on which it's based,
one iconic scene is especially faithful to the
original work: The birth of Doctor Manhattan.
Being the only character in the
story with actual superpowers,
Doctor Manhattan's creation is suitably dramatic.
After being accidentally locked in a test chamber,
scientist Jon Osterman is literally torn apart by
an experimental generator and left as a powerful,
disembodied consciousness. Over the next
few months, Jon learns to rebuild himself,
finally re-appearing as an
omnipotent blue superman.
Narrated to perfection by Billy Crudup, the
entire sequence is both haunting and riveting.
Years before he made history as Thanos in
the MCU, Josh Brolin portrayed one of DC's
more obscure anti-heroes: the bounty hunter
Jonah Hex. While the 2010 Jonah Hex film
alters the character somewhat by giving him
the mystical power of resurrecting the dead,
it does at least retain Hex's most distinctive
feature - his heavily scarred face.
In the movie, Hex is disfigured after his
Confederate commanding officer Quentin
Turnbull brands Hex's face with his initials.
Hex then removes the brand by intentionally
scarring that half of his face. Later,
a smart-mouthed thug asks what happened
to his face while brandishing a knife.
Hex guns him down, then simply quips:
"Cut myself shaving. What happened to yours?"
Green Lantern is a movie so thoroughly mocked that
even its star Ryan Reynolds has
taken a well-deserved shot at it.
"You're welcome, Canada."
Despite the film's problems, however, there is
one standout scene, in which Hal recites the Green
Lantern Oath and is propelled through a wormhole
to Oa, the home planet of the Green Lantern Corps.
Hal flies over a vast sprawl of futuristic
buildings, past the central Power Battery, and
into an assembly of Lanterns, who reveal that he's
now part of something much bigger than himself.
The Dark Knight Rises offers one iconic scene
that's actually deceptively low-key for a Batman
movie. In the film's final scenes, Bruce's butler
Alfred Pennyworth takes a holiday to Italy and
spies Bruce sitting at a nearby table with Selina
Kyle, having finally let go of his vigilante
lifestyle. Alfred then leaves, happy that Bruce
has found happiness outside of Gotham City.
Unlike other Batman films, which suggest that the
Dark Knight is eternally locked into his crusade,
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy offers something new: closure.
Here, and nowhere else, Bruce Wayne is finally
able to enjoy the happy ending he deserves.
Zack Snyder's Man of Steel is
full of controversial choices.
From the movie's grim tone to
Superman's decision to kill
General Zod at the story's climax, this
film continues to divide fans to this day.
One scene, however, truly embraces the joy of
being Superman. Upon discovering a Kryptonian
scout ship in the Arctic, Clark Kent dons
his Kryptonian suit and steps into the sun,
ready to learn how to fly. Gradually, Clark
progresses from super leaps to actual flight,
soaring through clouds and canyons
before finally reaching orbit.
The look on Superman's face as he realizes
what he can be is genuinely heart-warming,
and demonstrates the true
potential of Superman at his best.
Batman v Superman attracted all kinds of criticism
when it was released in 2016, but one thing the
movie did get right was the titular showdown
between the Man of Steel and the Dark Knight.
"Tell me… do you bleed?"
This sequence sees an older,
deadlier Bruce Wayne employ
everything from sonic cannons to Kryptonite
gas, to gain the edge on his god-like opponent.
And it works, too - although the two
eventually stop fighting to team up,
Batman definitely gets in a good few hits
against Superman, and, at one point, almost
takes him down for good. It's a potent reminder of
just how powerful a well-prepared Batman can be.
While Suicide Squad received countless
dire reviews from the critics, many of
them at least praised both the action and Margot
Robbie's performance as Harley Quinn. However,
it's another character, Will Smith's Deadshot,
who stars in the movie's most iconic scene.
When his team ends up fighting an army
of demonic monsters, the master assassin
Deadshot manages to convince the villains
to fight alongside the military to survive.
Then, just as the demons threaten to overwhelm
them, Deadshot steps up. He uses his uncanny
aim and an arsenal of weaponry to take out
every single demon, even as they get close
enough to tear him apart. By the end of the
film, Deadshot is still anything but a hero,
but he has still managed to earn the respect
of even his hard-nosed military handler.
Wonder Woman's best scene perfectly
communicates exactly who Wonder Woman
is, and where her strengths lie as a hero.
After accompanying Steve Trevor to Europe
to help fight World War I, Diana finds
herself on the frontlines in Belgium.
Here, Steve claims that moving through the
battlefield is more or less impossible,
as the men have been fighting for months and
barely gained an inch of ground in that time.
In response, Diana removes her cloak, climbs
the parapet and begins to walk across no man's
land. A barrage of bullets and bombs try to bring
her down, but the Amazonian princess refuses to
give up, eventually leading the Allied forces to
victory. It's a stunningly-shot action sequence
that really shows Wonder Woman for the
inspirational symbol of strength that she is.
The theatrical release of Justice League
greatly altered Zack Snyder's original vision.
As such, it's also deeply unpopular among
the fans - who successfully lobbied for
the release of Zack Snyder's
Justice League in March 2021.
One scene, however, did excite many fans back
in 2017. After being resurrected by an alien
"Mother Box," Superman emerges from his tomb in an
amnesiac state, and almost immediately attacks the
newly-formed Justice League. Their combined
might isn't nearly enough to restrain him,
of course, and he even proves himself fast
enough to keep up with the Flash himself.
Obviously, Superman later returns as the
Justice League's ally - but this scene
did a pretty great job in showing why you
don't mess with the last son of Krypton.
Fully embracing the fantastical
aspects of the character,
Aquaman immerses its hero in an Atlantis
bursting with color and life. There,
he accepts a quest to recover a powerful trident
that will grant him control over all sea life.
What this really means is made clear in the
movie's climactic battle scene, in which Aquaman
shows up to an all-out war between opposing
undersea kingdoms. Drawing on his enhanced powers,
Aquaman summons an army of sharks, whales,
and sea monsters that utterly overwhelms
his opponents. It might sound like
a silly power on paper, but Aquaman
showed - for the first time on screen - that
Arthur Curry's powers really are no joke.
At the heart of Shazam! is every kid's
wish: to become an all-powerful superhero.
The first half of the film takes a
comedic approach to this premise, as
14-year-old Billy Batson gains the ability
to transform into a fully adult superhero.
"Hey, to fighting bad guys.
That tastes like actual vomit."
However, the film's best scene comes at the
climax, when Billy stumbles onto a unique solution
to stop the evil Dr. Sivana and his Seven Deadly
Sins: sharing his power with his foster siblings.
As the kids all shout "Shazam!," a bolt of
lightning transforms them into fully-grown
superheroes, ready to take on Sivana's army. While
comic book fans might already be familiar with the
Shazam family, this scene will doubtless surprise
and delight all kinds of fans in equal measure.
Joker is a movie that managed to do what no other
DC film does: turn the Clown Prince of Crime into
a genuinely sympathetic character. The constant
abuse levied against failed comedian Arthur
Fleck comes to a head when he's invited onto a
late night talk show hosted by Murray Franklin,
the man he once idolized. Having previously
been pushed to the edge by Murray's ridicule,
Arthur - now fully inhabiting the Joker
persona - decides to take his revenge.
Originally planning to shoot
himself on live television,
Arthur changes his mind at the last second...
and shoots Murray in the face instead.
No longer an insecure sad-sack, this
is a Joker who has fully embraced
his demons - showing how the most human
supervillains can be the very worst of all.
Margot Robbie reprised her role as the Joker's
ex-girlfriend Harley Quinn in Birds of Prey,
and the result is an off-the-wall film filled
with delirious fun. The full title of the movie
speaks to the film's broader aims, while
its best scene perfectly communicates them:
It's all about helping Harley
and the Birds find themselves.
After being dumped by the Joker, Harley decides
to reinvent herself by blowing up Ace Chemicals,
the factory where the Joker transformed her
into his chalk-white counterpart. Although
Harley makes this decision when she's drunk and
feeling impulsive, it's still a fantastic moment
of rebirth that decisively separates Harley
from the Joker's influence. As the factory goes
up in an explosion of flaming green smoke and
Charlotte Lawrence's "The Joke's on You" plays
in the background, all of Gotham City learns
that Harley Quinn is finally her own woman.
Wonder Woman 1984 shows off a
more vulnerable side to Diana;
one who accidentally wishes for her dead
lover Steve Trevor to return to her.
Her wish comes true, but as a consequence,
Diana's power begins to fade. This becomes
a problem when she and Steve travel to Egypt
where the film's antagonist, Maxwell Lord,
has taken control of an oil tycoon's personal
army. As Wonder Woman takes on the entire convoy,
she discovers her reduced strength, speed,
and stamina make the battle much harder.
It's a very different side to Wonder
Woman, especially compared to the one
we saw storming No Man's Land in
the first movie. Despite it all,
she refuses to back down - and that's
what makes the scene so memorable.
One thing most people agree on about Zack
Snyder's vision of the DCEU is that it's all
pretty dark. This is made abundantly
clear in Zack Snyder's Justice League,
and arguably the film's most iconic
scene is the most despondent of all.
For its epilogue, the movie
returns to the apocalyptic
"Knightmare" future first
seen in Batman v Superman,
in which Superman has turned to evil and Earth
has been overrun with Darkseid's Parademons.
Most surprising of all, Batman has entered
into an alliance with his archenemy,
the Joker. The partnership is purely one
of convenience, of course, and the Joker
still takes sick joy in tormenting
the Dark Knight with his failures.
"And I'm happy to discuss with you, in any
way you like, why you sent a boy wonder
to do a man's job."
Naturally, Batman promises to one day
make his archenemy really pay for his
crimes. But this is a dynamic rarely
depicted in DC's live-action movies,
and it'd no doubt be fascinating to
see it further explored in the future.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.